all right next question from Facebook
Rebecca
Eleanor Pfeiffer asks why v-necks what
do you have against round collared
shirts Rebecca on Facebook is asking me
why I don't wear what we call crew neck
t-shirt so you can call them round
collar yes if you want a more convoluted
way to describe it but maybe that blame
goes to Rebecca and not you maybe I'm
being unfair and situation
Rebecca those are called crew neck
shirts with all due respect and I'm
wearing one right now I also wear
v-necks at times it's really a question
of releasing heat ok now the human
body's internal core temperature is 98.6
degrees as we all know even though
nothing else around us is that
temperature that means that we are
raising our own core temperature and
expending energy and doing so that
energy normally comes from the food that
we eat we also sometimes if we cover
ourselves with too many clothes or a
jacket that's too thick we may say this
makes me hot in fact the jacket or the
blanket doesn't make you hot as much as
it prevents you from releasing your own
heat you understand your body internally
is 98.6 degrees my responsibility to
stay at an externally comfortable
temperature is to release that heat into
the environment if I'm covered it
impedes that release which could be
beneficial in a cold climate in that
case you don't want to release your heat
because you can't make the heat quickly
enough to counteract the cold of the
environment however in a hotter
environment you do want to release that
heat in the way you do that is by
exposing as much of your skin as
possible to the environment and short
sleeve shirts are a way to do that
shorts are a way to do that and a v-neck
t-shirt is another way to do that by
exposing the area of my neck to the
environment I am releasing more heat so
it's not a fashion choice it's is a is a
temperature choice for you it is a your
it's a it's a body choice it's a it's a
physiological rather than fashion I
think the fit of a t-shirt is a very
critical thing I think that way well in
the same way that the simplest pastas
are the most difficult to cook the
simplest articles of clothing
often the most complex when it terms
when it comes to the subtleties of them
and I think the fit of a t-shirt between
the shoulders the chest and the waist
that holy triumvirate is is a delicate
combination and of a certain brand fits
you you may not care whether it's a
crewneck or a v-neck
now if you will just cast your eye your
critical eye upon this t-shirt yeah well
for sure I'm gonna do a quick slow
motion turn what do you think about this
you know even if you had turned more
quickly I would have had the acuity to
follow and make form an opinion okay I'm
gonna tell you that first we need to
talk about your body before we talk
about the shirt because every shirt fits
differently on different bodies the
question is how well does that shirt fit
your body and what is the ratio between
your chest your waist and your shoulders
I can tell you that if I were to cast a
critical eye I would say it fits your
waist very well there's no excess
material and there's no excess bulk I
would say that it's you don't have to
raise your hands to the side back that
distorts the dirty shirt okay I would
say that with your arms straight down it
is a little tight in the pectoralis
Majoris I can see the outline of your
right nipple on my left side I can tell
you that in that sense it's a little too
tight your left pocket distracts and
possibly obscures that nipple from being
visible however the shoulders seem to
fit perfectly and and all in all I'd say
it's a valiant effort the problem for
you is the chest area and again that's
only a credit to you and how much you've
built those chest muscles up if your
chest muscles weren't as strong the
shirt would fit better but at what price
so you're saying basically it's
shoulders good waist good nipples
visible now I'm not gonna say that's too
tight I'm gonna say that it's tight and
the nipples are visible if that's a
stylistic choice or a choice that you
prefer that's fine as well in that case
you have succeeded yes you know we all
have our own personal sense of style and
if that's how you choose to express
yours that's fine
I didn't want my nipple you know I don't
think about my nipples
so you're saying ideally your nipples
would not be visible well I got people
looking my nipple I mean I'm not saying
people are looking at it I'm only
it's visible people can decide what they
choose to look at if someone wants to
look at your elbow right or your I mean
sternum why do men still have nipples
anyway
like i don't use these nipples for
anything well you do understand that
human evolution is thousands of years
behind societal advances right I mean do
you understand why people have cravings
for food and cravings to eat more than
they should for optimal health is based
on evolution a period when your next
meal wouldn't necessarily come for days
and you would need a large amount of
calories to support large bursts of
energy for fight-or-flight right well
okay all right well Jordan thank you so
much this was very enlightening in in
every possible way thank you for taking
us through your office and you guys you
can follow Jordan on Instagram and
snapchat at Jordan shlonsky it's spelled
just like it sounds and yeah I was a
pleasure thanks this has been a mutually
satisfying experience see myself out
you